un château 19e siècle typique du Val de
Loire à seulement quelques kilomètres de
Chaumont-sur-Loire Cheverny Chenonceau
dans le parc un bientôt allemand
atypique et proposé à la vente
cet ancienne usine transforme en hôtel
insolite
[Musique]
j'ai voulu surtout recréer un esprit
tapissier donc un électricité chose
traditionnelle tapissière avec ses
bourrelets c'est calpinage
donc c'est un fait sur une base de
couard de fibre de coco Paul Valois a
œuvré 10 années de sa vie pour
réhabiliter cette ancienne école de
tourneur-fraiseur une folie réalisée par
cet artisan artiste là est-ce que
Monsieur valoir réalisé c'est une vraie
oeuvre d'art c'est à dire que là on est
dans un lieu extrêmement singulier dans
un lieu qui a une âme qui a une identité
qui a une histoire et ça c'est
typiquement ce que ce qu'on sélectionne
dans notre catalogue est-ce que nos
clients recherchent
11 chambres dont un duplex un mur
végétalisé des cuisines aménagées même
le passe-plat est fonctionnel finalement
tout est prêt tout est prêt il suffit
qu'un investisseur est envie de
s'installer absolument tout est tout est
prêt
voilà le retour autocuisine
[Musique]
on est dans une usine qui est dans le
parc d'un château un château de 19e et
donc la clientèle d'un château du 19e va
être une clientèle très souvent
anglo-saxonne je parle sous le contrôle
de Monsieur Valois mais dans les bords
de Loire c'est vraiment ce qui est
recherché et ici on va aussi aller
chercher une clientèle française une
clientèle plus locale ou parisienne qui
va vouloir être dans des lieux insolites
qui va vouloir venir s'offrir une nuitée
un peu différente
ce type de bien si atypique dans un
secteur très touristique pourrait
intéresser un investisseur
mis à prix un million d'euros
[Musique]
un bien exceptionnel dans un segment
très particulier à 70 km de la
Romorantin le marché de l'immobilier
classique et très dynamique en un an le
prix des biens à la vente a augmenté de
15%
[Musique]
. nous c'est assez actif le marché on a
l'impression Christophe là
des maisons à vendre comme celle-ci oui
il y a vraiment beaucoup d'activités en
ce moment pourtant on est en plein hiver
pas de saison le marché il est actif les
changements de vie on n'attend pas l'été
pour changer de vie on n'attend pas
l'été pour être muté on n'attend pas
l'été pour divorcer on n'attend pas donc
il y a toujours il y a toujours
d'activité tous les moments de l'année
Christophe Gauthier est un enfant du
pays depuis 15 ans il sillonne la
Sologne à la recherche de biens
immobiliers
là on est sur la plutôt sur une grosse
maison centre-ville maison voilà
bourgeoise on a de la brique on voit de
la pierre à l'entourage des fenêtres
donc maison très bien entretenu en très
bon état avec des volumes intéressants
un garage donc ça ce qui est quand même
plutôt bien en centre-ville et puis une
terrasse aujourd'hui on a une typologie
de bien qui est tellement importante on
a une clientèle qui veut du centre-ville
on a une clientèle qui veut être un
petit peu à l'extérieur une clientèle
qui veut 4000 m² de terrain qui ont tel
qu'il veut 200 mètres carrés de terrain
donc je vais pas dire que celle-ci est
plus recherchée qu'une autre tous les
biens peuvent être recherchés
le marché Romorantin est très diversifié
les locaux veulent plus grand ou plus
petit en fonction des étapes de la vie
les Parisiens eux recherchent un bien
pour changer de vie on a eu une offre
hier de clients qui viennent de la
région parisienne pour venir sur prunier
en Sologne voilà l'exemple type de ce
qui de ce qui vient de se produire
Christophe Gauthier a ouvert son agence
franchisée en 2021 après deux ans
d'activité la base de données est déjà
bien remplie son fichier
435 clients acheteurs pour une
soixantaine de biens à vendre
je suis pas simple de dire ce que je
veux dire mais le covid a été positif
dans la partie immobilière ça c'est
clair on peut pas se voiler la face
c'est quelque chose qui nous a apporté
nous voilà une clientèle de l'extérieur
et
c'est quelque chose qui a fait
développer le marché local à Romorantin
et puis sûrement sur des communes
extérieures aussi dans d'autres villes
dans les autres villes de la région
justement le marché de l'immobilier se
porte encore très bien
[Musique]
la palme pour ce village prisé Rueil la
Gadelière dans le Perche après de 4300
euros le mètre carré
Saint-Cyr-sur-Loire au nord de Tours
3900 euros le mètre carré
d'autres communes d'indres Loire trust
les places de ce classement des villes
les plus chères de la région
[Musique]
si l'on regarde l'évolution des prix sur
5 ans l'immobilier a connu un boom
impressionnant plus 41% à Tours 35%
Orléans 29% à Blois
osent également sensible à Chartres
Châteauroux et Bourges
[Musique]
mais la hausse des taux d'intérêt et
l'inflation vont sans doute contraindre
les vendeurs à revoir leur prétention à
la baisse
après des années fast dans l'immobilier
la fête semble bel et bien fini
bonjour enchanté
pour la première fois à un courtier en
crédit
ses professionnels du prêt accompagnent
particuliers et professionnels pour
financer un projet mon objectif c'est de
mettre en concurrence les différents
établissements bancaires pour pouvoir
vous obtenir le meilleur taux
manque de temps mes connaissances
techniques et peu d'envie sont les
raisons pour lesquelles certains
s'attachent leur service
pour m'aider dans mes démarches parce
que j'ai pas beaucoup de connaissances
là dessus et c'est pour surtout m'aider
dans mes démarches
le fondateur de cette agence c'est lui
Loïc gibier en 2004 il lance son cabinet
de courtage à l'époque cette pratique
est encore confidentielle en France moi
quand j'ai démarré il y a 20 ans
clairement il y avait un courtier qui
existait un continental
et ça représentait peut-être un ou deux
pourcents des dossiers qui étaient faits
à l'heure actuelle on a évolué vers une
tendance à 40 40% des dossiers qui sont
présentés
dans cet agence on a donc une idée
précise de la conjoncture actuelle avec
un léger tassement du marché en ce début
d'année pas encore sur les prix mais sur
le nombre de transactions
les taux augmentaient très fort très
vite mais les prix d'achat eux n'ont pas
baissé donc on se retrouve encore une
fois avec des des biens qui ont une
valeur
quelle qu'elle soit on peut pas
aujourd'hui juger de la valeur d'un bien
surtout on peut pas demander à un
vendeur de baisser son prix aussi vite
que la hausse des taux mais on a par
contre en face des acquéreurs qui ont
des capacités d'endettement qui
réduisent et bah les revenus eux ne ment
pas comment savoir une confrontation
quand même entre la hausse des taux et
le prix des marchés immobiliers qui qui
ont quand même freiné la volumétrie
conséquence de cette tendance les
premiers touchés sont les
primo-accédants avec la hausse des taux
d'intérêt et sans apport difficile
d'accéder à la propriété
[Musique]
ouais c'est un marché qui est cohérent
ça fait ça fait à peu près 70 ventes à
l'année 70 ans à l'année c'est un marché
actif
[Musique]
on est sur une maison
ancienne mais qui a toujours été bien
entretenu voilà PVC double vitrage même
des volets roulants
une maison dans son jus d'une centaine
de mètres carrés des beaux volumes un
jeune couple a pu racheter ce bien à la
baisse 108.000 euros frais d'agence
inclus là comme tout client ils vont
mettre leurs pattes personnelles
aujourd'hui mais eux ils vont apporter
leur pas de personnel donc c'est aussi
ça le charme de pouvoir transformer des
maisons de pouvoir les faire revivre
leur donner une nouvelle vie une
nouvelle âme avec des nouveaux
propriétaires et aujourd'hui il commence
par celle-ci c'est une maison qui
deviendra peut-être un investissement
immobilier dans quelques années et puis
la mettront en location sur un nouveau
projet donc ouais c'est important c'est
important c'est important de commencer
jeune dans l'investissement
à 5 minutes du centre de Romorantin le
jeune couple pourra en plus profiter des
longues et belles soirées d'été
[Musique]
mais les vendeurs sont-ils prêts à céder
moins cher partout dans certains
quartiers très prisés des métropoles la
baisse n'est pas encore pour demain
comme par exemple dans ce secteur très
prisé à Tours les préventes en
particularité vous avez vu la hauteur de
plafond on est très loin de 6 mètres
plafond
spécificités d'ailleurs de ces de ces
poutrelles métalliques si vous
connaissez un peu la ville de Tours ce
sont les mêmes que la garde voilà
puisque ce sont les mêmes artisans qui
en 1860 avaient effectivement en
parallèle de la gare fait ce bâtiment à
l'époque
[Musique]
magalie est conseillère dans une agence
de bien atypique
alors quand un client lui propose à la
vente se loft en plein centre de Tours
des gens qui cherchent un Love qui
cherche un bien qui ne soit pas comme
celui du voisin comme les autres oui
effectivement on a beaucoup de clients
qui cherchent des biens qui des biens
singulier des biens qui ont qui ont une
âme une particularité des volumes comme
ça c'est très recherché
Nicolas et sa femme ont pratiquement
tout fait eux-mêmes dans ce loft après
huit années d'une tranche de vie ils ont
ressenti le besoin de passer à autre
chose alors c'est très atypique on y est
très bien d'ailleurs c'est pas ce qui
nous fait partir c'est pas le lieu c'est
qu'on a trouvé tout simplement une autre
opportunité plus campagnarde donc c'est
vraiment un choix de vie complet de
vouloir effectivement quitter ce lieu
alors je pense quand il sera vendu on
aura un petit pincement au cœur parce
qu'on a quand même investi beaucoup de
temps beaucoup de beaucoup de temps
là-dessus mais voilà c'est le plaisir
effectivement de d'aller aussi vers
d'autres aventures
pour Sébastien Boisset vice-président à
la Chambre des notaires du Val de Loire
on est arrivé à la fin d'un cycle mais
l'immobilier reste une valeur sûre une
belle refuge et puis un bon
investissement puisque le général bon
rendement pour ceux qui investissent
dans le locatif peut avoir des
rendements à 5 6% voire dans les villes
moyennes parfois 10
l'argent ne génère pas autant de de
revenus de rendement et avec la
problématique des passoires énergétiques
et l'obligation de faire des travaux
d'isolation la tendance du marché
pourrait s'inverser avec une baisse des
prix en faveur cette fois des acquéreurs
et à une volonté du gouvernement de
pousser vers la rénovation énergétique
avec des sanctions directes ou
indirectes si jamais effectivement le
logement répond pas aux normes
pas la capacité et qui n'ont pas l'envie
de faire ces travaux du coup ça va
remettre des biens sur le marché
exactement ça va revenir remettre des
biens sur le marché peut-être qu'avec
des prix inférieurs puisque l'acheteur
lui devra faire les travaux de
rénovation énergétique pour pouvoir le
louer
l'état énergétique d'un bien est donc
devenu un critère de choix en tout cas
la baisse escomptée amorcée au niveau
national sera peut-être salutaire pour
assainir enfin le marché
[Musique]